we're on problem 61.
if one kilometer is approximately 0.6
miles
one kilometer is approximately 0.6 miles
which of the following best approximates
the number of kilometers in two miles
so we want to know two miles
so we could set up a ratio we could say
0.6
is to two right point six miles r to two
miles
as
one kilometer is to x kilometers
you could cross multiply i could say 0.6
is equal to 2
and that x is equal to 2 divided by 0.6
which is the same thing as
20
divided by 6
right
20 divided by 6 is equal to
3
and 2 6. right three and one-third
three and one-third
three and one-third kilometers and that
makes sense right a mile is longer than
a kilometer so two miles is about three
and one-third kilometers and that's not
one of the choices but if we wrote this
as an improper fraction three times
three is nine plus one is ten
so that equals ten over three
kilometers which is choice a
a
let me do a brighter color i don't know
if you can even see this
62.
lucy invested ten thousand dollars in a
new mutual fund account exactly three
years ago
ten thousand dollars three years ago
the value of the account increased by
ten percent during the first year
so plus ten percent during the first
year
increased by five percent during the
second year plus five percent during the
second year and decreased by ten percent
and then decreased by ten percent during
the third year what is the value of the
account today
so you start with ten thousand dollars
when you grow by ten percent that's the
same thing as multiplying by one point
one
right
right it's like one plus point one
times whatever so that's multiplying by
point one one point one and then you
grow by another five percent that's like
multiplying by 1.05
and then when you decrease by 10 percent
that's like multiplying by 0.9
so we need to figure out what this is
this is this is a little bit
a little bit of math for us to do so 1.1
times 10 000. that's at least fairly
straightforward that's 11 000
right that's how much we have after year
one
11 000 and we have to multiply that
times 1.05
and then times and then we lose 10
percent
so 11 000 times 1.05
well just to make sure i get it right
just so i don't make a careless mistake
let's actually do it
11 000
times
1.05
so five times eleven thousand is fifty
five thousand
and then we should add two zero the zero
doesn't matter so we had two zeros
and then one times eleven thousand is
eleven thousand
you add them up you get zero zero zero
five five one one and we have two
digits behind the decimal
point so
we got eleven thousand five fifty which
is right i mean
i would have been it would have been
weird if we got a hundred thousand or if
we got one thousand right we only had a
what five percent change so then we have
eleven thousand
five fifty
and now we now it's going to decrease
by 10
or we could multiply it by 0.9
i don't know it might be easier just to
take out 10 percent let's multiply it by
0.9
times 0.9
0.9
nine times zero is zero nine times zero
is zero nine times five is forty-five
nine times one is nine plus four is
thirteen
nine times one is nine plus one is ten
and we have one digit behind the decimal
point within which we it's right there
so we're left with ten thousand three
hundred and fifty dollars and that is
choice a
next
problem next problem 63
63 and they give us this table
they say a computer chip manufacturer
expects the ratio of the number of
defective chips to the total number of
chips in all future shipments to equal
the corresponding
ratio
for shipments as combined as shown table
what is the expected number
in the shipment
okay so let me write down what they
wrote so that where we see the same
thing so shipment
shipment and they label them
s1
s2
s3
and s4
and they need to ask us the number
of defective
chips
in the shipment i know you can't read my
handwriting
two
five
six
and four
and then they say the total number of
ship chips
total
in each shipment
is five thousand
five thousand
twelve thousand
eighteen thousand
eighteen thousand and sixteen thousand
now let's reread the question maybe
it'll make a little bit more sense a
computer chip manufacturer expects the
ratio of the number of defective chips
so defective chips
to the total number of ships so that's
defective to total
in all future chip in all future
shipments to equal the corresponding
ratio for shipments
s1 through s4 combined
okay as shown in the table above
is equal to let me make sure i read that
in all future to equal the corresponding
ratio for shipments s1 s2 s3
and s4 combine and show the table off
what is the expected number of defective
chips in a shipment of 60 000.
so they're saying essentially if we take
all if we take these shipments combined
what percentage were defective and
that's the same number we would expect
to be defective in a shipment of 60 000.
so let's figure out what percentage are
defective so how many total were
defective seven two plus five is seven
seven plus six is thirteen
thirteen plus four
is seventeen
and how many total
chips did we ship
seventeen thousand
seventeen plus eighteen
is thirty five 35 plus 16
35 plus 16 is 41 is equal to 51 000
chips
51 000.
so we could view it a couple of ways
let's it's 17 for every 51 000
where we're defective but actually
if you haven't realized it already 51 is
divisible by 17 that's one that a lot of
people miss 17 times three so if we
divide both of these numbers by 17 we
say
we can say that one chip for every
3000
is defective
if we take shipments s1 through s4
combined one chip in every 3000
and so if we have that same ratio for
sixty thousand chips
well how many groups of three thousand
are there in sixty thousand well there
are twenty of them right we could say
one and three thousand
is equal to x over sixty thousand
and you could eyeball this to some
degree or you could just say you know
what can i multiply both the numerator
and denominator this by to get sixty
thousand well if i multiply the
numerator and the denominator by twenty
i get
twenty over 60 000 you could cross
multiply there's a bunch of ways you
could do this but the bottom line is
that you would expect 20 defective chips
and that is choice
b
b
problem 64.
do it in this color
let's see they tell us that a is equal
to a set of numbers i don't know what
the context is yet 2 3
4 and five
and they tell us that b is equal to
another set of numbers
four
five
six
seven
and eight
two integers will be randomly selected
from the sets above one integer from set
a and one integer from set b
what is probability that the sum of the
two integers will equal nine
is equal is equal will equal 9.
so let's think about all of the
combinations
that equal 9
right
so
if
so no matter what
so all of these so if i pick
2
from this set
right each of these course if i pick 2
from this
i have to pick 7 from here
right if i pick 3 from this set i have
to pick 6 from here if i pick four from
this set i have to pick five from here
if i pick five from this set i have to
pick four from here
right
so no matter what so you know i'm gonna
pick one of these numbers right from set
one it's going to be two three or four
or five and depending which of these
pick i have to pick the exact right
number from set b
so think of it this way i don't know
what i picked in set a right i don't
know let's say we've picked one of them
we don't know which of these we've
picked and we know that exactly one of
these is going to be the right number to
add to whatever we've picked to equal 9.
so we have and we have to pick that
exactly right one and we're going to be
picking it out of a selection of one two
three four five numbers so we have a one
and five chance of having them add up to
nine and one and five is the same thing
as point two which is choice b i hope
that makes sense you can say look i
don't care what i pick from set one i
could pick any of these and in order for
it to add up from nine so i you know i
know i can pick any random one from
there's a no matter what i pick from
here there's a one-fifth chance that i
pick the right corresponding number that
that adds up to nine there because each
of these have only one that you have if
i picked three i have to pick five right
so if i if i picked if i pick two i have
to pick
seven if i pick three i have to pick
five
if i pick
if i pick
six i have to pick
three
and if i pick three i have to pick six
and if i pick oh no sorry if i pick four
i have to pick five if i pick five i
have to pick 4 right
and so you could say well the chances of
each of these are one-fifth
actually i'm not going to go down that
road all you have to say is
that this complicates overly complicated
all you have to say is look i'm going to
pick one of these and once i have one of
those in my hand there's a one-fifth
chance that i picked the exact one that
adds up to what whatever i just picked
to equal nine so the answer is b
and now i am out of time see you next
video